[Music]
thank you
there we go Prince Harry leaving there
with two brief waves to the press and a
thumbs up and a and a small smile I
would say a couple of fans here
a couple of fans here waving their
copies of his books Fair hoping to get
an autograph Sally that didn't happen
for them a few shouts of I love you
Prince Harry that wasn't me shouting
that that was someone else
certainly someone standing right next to
me you might have heard it on on my
microphone but yeah certainly an
extraordinary couple of days here at the
high court Prince Harry has just left
after two days of evidence here and he
looked at he looked pretty upbeat he'd
had obviously a big debrief with his
media with his legal team following his
evidence today
proceedings ended around well 45 minutes
ago nearly and Prince Harry's been
inside Consulting with his Barrister
David Sherborn until now and that was
him just leaving two quick ways to the
press a thumbs up and a brief smile